haute de bouaine bonjour bienvenue dans
la matinale de rtl france alors avec la
crise sanitaire et l'arrêt du tourisme
votre activité a dû s'arrêter
brutalement alors depuis racontez nous
comment cela s'est passé comment est ce
que vous avez été aidés si vous l'avez
été d'ailleurs alors les guides
conférenciers en sont pour une part en
travailleur indépendant et eux ont été
aidées depuis le mois de mars grâce à
l'attribution du fonds de solidarité
donc cela dure encore et comme vous
l'avez dit précédemment ça va diminuer
très rapidement sur cet été pour ce qui
est des salariés malheureusement la
situation était complètement différent
puisqu'on a très très peu eu accès au
chômage partiel et plus du tout
maintenant puisque en général les guides
conférenciers ou des missions qui sont
confirmées pour plus de 50% d'entre
elles à 50 à moins de deux semaines de
la réalisation des visites donc on a
vraiment très populeux et les fichiers
des du chômage partiel et on a eu une
prolongation des indemnités chômage qui
a été accordée pendant deux mois de mai
de mars à mai l'année dernière les sept
années de novembre jusqu'à mai mais là
maintenant la situation est toujours
très très problématique puisque les
touristes ne sont pas de retour donc 80%
des guides conférenciers le travail avec
des touristes étrangers
et une fois que ces aides vont s'arrêter
ça va être assez catastrophique
puisqu'on aura absolument pas de revenus
la seule possibilité ce sont des
visioconférences puisque beaucoup de
musées ne nous ouvre pas leurs portes et
pour le moment on a un problème de jauge
c'est à dire qu'on peut aller dans des
musées en fonction de ce qu'ils
acceptent comme nombre de comme taille
de groupe mais la seule bonne nouvelle
qu'on a eu pour le moment
ça a été d'avoir une élargissement de la
taille des groupes possibles pour les
guides conférenciers professionnels et
là ont remercié le secrétaire d'état la
voie vraiment eu cette précision c'est à
dire que ça soit pour les professionnels
parce qu'on a en plus une concurrence
avec des frais taux des personnes qui le
ne sont pas professionnels et qui
s'improvise guide conférencier donc on a
une inquiétude pour notre fin d'année si
on peut dire deuxième moitié de l'année
2021 et 2022
alors combien de personnes seront
conservés pour se rendre compte et et
pour être guide conférencier qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire comme parcours alors on
est actuellement à peu près 4000 à 5000
guide conférencier qui vivent de notre
métier qui vivions de notre métier et
pour refaire le pour devenir guide
conférencier en fait vous avez des
formations en licence professionnelle ou
quand vous faites des masters de +11 ti
cursus complémentaires qui vous permet
d'avoir tout la formation en langues en
médiation culturelle pour ça va
transmettre en fait toutes ces
informations que l'on accumulé au fil
des années et on a une possibilité aussi
de 20 de validation d'acquis
d'expérience pour les personnes qui ont
déjà travaillé beaucoup dans le tourisme
ou dans les musées par exemple et qui
veulent en plus devenir guide
conférencier on le voit des bagages des
paillages important pour devenir guide
conférencier est ce qu'après cette
situation catastrophique pour vous vous
demandez une évolution de votre statut
lorsqu'on demande déjà c'est d'avoir au
moins un poursuite des aides dans un
premier temps parce que comme le pour
les intermittents du spectacle vous avez
une prolongation de leur indemnité pour
nous ça serait un ca serait
indispensable parce qu'on voit pas
comment les guides conférenciers vont
pouvoir tenir si jamais il n'y a pas du
tout d'être qui sont maintenus après les
trois mois prochain
et pour la modification de notre statut
ce qu'on aimerait c'est d'avoir plus de
contrôle de l'activité des guides de non
professionnels parce que de plus en plus
si vous voulez notre métier père de fin
on a de plus en plus de mal finalement à
effectuer notre métier que d'une
concurrence déloyale
est ce qu'on aimerait donc c'est d'avoir
par exemple une carte professionnelle
qui soit reconnaissable par tous un peu
plus de médiatisation de la part des
pouvoirs publics sur ce qu'est ce
un guide comme un guide conférencier
parce qu'on s'est aperçu qu'en fait
notre métier et est très méconnue et
nous on est vraiment des passionnés de
la culture dans tout cela le taille de
ce que ça représente c'est à dire aussi
bien la gastronomique la vie quotidienne
que l'histoire de l'art l'histoire en
général les petites anecdotes et c'est
ce qui fait le grand plaisir de notre de
notre métier alors ses petites anecdotes
on va pouvoir les lire et entendre avec
la réouverture prochaine des musées est
ce que c'est une vraie lueur d'espoir où
il ya encore des incertitudes
alors c'est une lueur d'espoir oui s'il
est dit qu si l'élite conférence y sont
autorisés à faire des visites dans les
musées et avec des conditions qui ne
sont pas trop drastiques parce que quand
on a une limitation à 5 ou 10 personnes
dans un musée qu'on vous demande des
droits d'entrée qui s'additionne à des
droits de visite conférence c'est à dire
que nous on doit régler 1
un droit de faire une visite commentée
dans un musée et en plus de vous avez là
dessus qu'ils vont s'ajouter les
montants des droits d'entrée
donc si vous voulez après quand vous
avez un petit groupe ils n'ont pas les
moyens en finale de la très souvent de
régler en plus de tout ça nos
prestations de guides conférenciers donc
ce qu'on aimerait bien c'est d'avoir un
coup de pouce des guides des musées en
doublettes du ministère de la culture
pour nous aider à faire un peu plus la
transmission du patrimoine français
parce qu'on a un patrimoine
extraordinaire
est ce que vous comptez sensibilité
sensibiliser aujourd'hui le grand public
à votre situation
et si oui comment alors on a le soutien
de l'office du tourisme et le soutien la
de la ville de paris par exemple avec
des visites qui vont être offertes aux
franciliens cet été comme ça l'a été
pour l'année proche pour le l'été
dernier on a le comité régional du
tourisme d'île de france qui va
également proposer des visites offerte
comme ça pour faire mieux connaître en
fait que le métier de guide conférencier
est un conférencier peut apporter sur la
découverte de son propre environnement
vous avez également à bordeaux des
visites qui vont être quasiment offert
qu'en fait c'étaient eux à 5 euros vous
allez pouvoir suivre une visite guidée
de la ville donc de du patrimoine de 9
et l'aquitaine
vous avez en normandie également le même
système qui va être mis en place donc on
a un petit soutien des pouvoirs publics
est ce qu'on espère c'est que justement
les aubes et tous les organismes du taux
les organisations du tourisme étatiques
en fait nous aide à faire la promotion
de notre métier et par ce biais de la
promotion du patrimoine des différentes
régions merci beaucoup aux deux bornes
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl frange le rappelle vous
êtes présidente de la fédération
nationale des guides interprètes et
conférencier